alors le maïs c'est la scène est un ring
les adversaires deux équipes de catcheur
et leurs arbres un texte écrit en direct
c'est le principe du chaos des mots
c'est particulier il faut arriver déjà à
a dépassé de simplement son blocage à
l'écrit et dans capacité à pouvoir
s'amuser du clavier et laisser libre
cours à son imaginaire par rapport à ce
qui est posée donc par exemple au
premier rand
on donne un équipes it c'est à dire la
première phrase d'un roman et il va
falloir continuer pendant cinq minutes
ce roman là parmi les joueurs des jeunes
issus de l'association escaladent qui
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
on se reconnaître dans le plaisir à
écrire et redonner plaisir à des gens
qui ont effectivement peut-être des
difficultés qui sont pas reconnus dans
leur écriture là d'un seul coup y ont
leur offre cette possibilité là de se
connecter avec bonheur et avec plaisir
elle des difficultés ajouté à chaque
round des pénalités en fonction des
fautes et pourquoi pas découvrir
l'écrivain de demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]